[MUSIC PLAYING]
Bernstein Mass is quite
the unusual piece of music.
And there's everything in it.
There's a rock band.
There's an organ.
There's an orchestra.
There's a boys choir.
I mean, you name it, the whole
shebang is in Bernstein Mass.
The dancers at UA School
of Dance are phenomenal.
They are so strong
and so diverse
in all genres between
ballet, modern, and jazz.
They are so excited to be
performing in Centennial Hall.
Such an amazing venue
to be performing in.
Five, six, seven.
The director of the
ballet is James Clouser,
and he has come
up with a concept
about JFK, the life of JFK.
He brought in lots of
characters from the '60s
to join in with the JFK story.
And it's about a nun that
never spoke, never said a word.
And all of the sudden,
through ecstasy of prayer,
she's found this
person inside of her.
The whole concept between
Bernstein Mass and then also
the JFK ballet is really about
finding faith and believing
in something.